[Arabic recitation]
Kitab al-Aziz
and we are in the midst of listing,
as the author here mentions and lists to
us with evidence,
each of the verifiable types of filth,
types of najasa.
So, this chapter here,
when we have one of the
principles or one of the conditions of
salah
is that a person purify himself,
his body, his clothing, his place of
salah, we have to know what it is that
we must purify ourselves from.
And so this chapter, or this sub chapter
more
correctly,
is enlisting these various types of
filth. When we say filth, najasa, we're
speaking about that which will
compromise a person's prayer.
And najasa ta'rif al-najasa huna
[Arabic recitation]
yuf silu
salat al-musalli.
Fa
itha kana yajib ala al-mar'
an yutahhir jasadahu wa yutahhir
[Arabic recitation]
wa an yata'ahhab al-salat kana hadha min
yajib alayna an na'lama
ma hiya al-ashya' allati yanbaghi
lil-insan an yutahhir nafsahu minha.
Fa hadhihi hiya al-najasaat.
Laysat hadhihi al-awsakh kullaha.
Thamma ashya' wasikha.
yastaqdiruha al-nas lakin qad takun
qad yakun shay' min al-ashya' wasikh
yastaqdiruhu al-insan lakin laysa bi
[Arabic recitation]
Lakin kullu najasa
min al-wasakh shay' wasikh.
Na'am.
So when we say the word filth, najasa,
this is a very specific term.
It's not just anything that makes a
person uncomfortable, anything that is
gross to the person, anything that is
is unclean.
Right?
Rather, filth is that which
we have learned through the Quran and
Sunnah which will compromise a person's
prayer. That is specifically what a
najasa is here.
There are many things that are unclean.
And it may be inappropriate for a person
to pray with these unclean things on
them, but it will not invalidate a
person's prayer.
So when we say you have to purify
yourself from these things, meaning what
are these things that we must purify
ourselves from? These are a najasat.
Right? And we are only going to mention
that which we find
a clear evidence for.
Right? That which we find a clear
evidence for. Sahihun sarihun.
That which is clear
and that which is authentic. Right? So
so far
we have read with the author six
types of things
which will
which are of the najasat. We've learned
six of them so far. Let's see if we can
list them quickly before we
mention number seven for this morning.
The first and second.
Y- urine and human urine and feces.
Okay, that's one and two. Three and
four.
Al-wady al-wady
wal-madhy. Right? So al-madhy
is what comes out when
al-madhy at arousal. Right? Comes with
sexual arousal.
it is pre-sperm
or
pre-ejaculate. And al-wady
with a dal, when does this come out?
After urinating. This This originates
from the bladder.
Right? And it is marked as being white
and cloudy and usually comes out within
5 minutes after urinating. These things
are also a type of najasa. We will
discuss in detail how to clean all of
these things
in the coming chapters cuz they're not
all clean the same way and they're not
all on the same level of filth. Because
there are that which is extremely filth,
a heightened level of najasa, that which
is
moderately or just regular najasa and
then that which is mildly najis. And
each of them has their way of cleaning.
The fifth one that we mentioned
yesterday
Any animal that is prohibited to eat.
The author here speci- specifies
the feces of any animal that is
prohibited to eat, but that's because
the narration is only mentioning that.
But it's anything from that animal which
is impermissible to eat. And then the
sixth thing that we mentioned yesterday
was
menstrual blood and with it comes
postpartum. Okay.
The seventh
thing that the author lists here, he
says lu'aabul kalb.
The saliva
of a dog.
The saliva of a dog.
[Silence]
Wal hadithu
indal Imam Muslim.
[Arabic recitation]
narration which is in sahih al-Imam
Muslim on the authority of Abu Hurayrah
who narrates that the messenger of Allah
sallallahu alayhi wasallam says
in order to purify
a vessel, a cup, a glass, a goblet,
something that a person drinks from, the
dish
that a dog has drank from
is that a person wash it seven times,
the first of those seven times being
with dirt.
Okay.
So, we see here that this is a
heightened level
of najasa. Right? It's a heightened
level of najasa.
Why? Because
even after you cannot smell, see
anything with your naked eye anymore
you still have to wash.
Right? So, the prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam tells us that with the
menstrual blood
she is to scrub it
rinse it
and then
rinse it. to scrub it, wring it
out, and then rinse it. That's it. And
we said even if a person sees a stain
after that
they they have they have done
their due diligence. But a person's
due diligence for this
is by number, not by sight, not by
smell, right? Not by taste.
And that is that a person must wash this
dish seven times
the first of which being with dirt. So,
here we have the number of times. This
is a bare minimum. And number two, we
have something else that is added to
water in order to purify more
using dirt. Why dirt? Well, soap wasn't
really a thing in the desert back then.
When a person wanted to clean something
and to scrub something properly, they
would use dirt, right? Is it acceptable
to use a detergent or a soap in place of
dirt today to purify this?
That is an issue that we will discuss in
the next chapter when we discuss
the things
that
how to purify these various types of
filth. Inshallah, we will go into more
detail.
But now, the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam here mentions the saliva of the
dog.
Well, what about the urine of the dog?
What about the feces of the dog?
[Arabic recitation]
The dog sweat?
Huh?
No, they don't sweat. That's why they
stick their tongues out. So, the saliva
of a dog or pus if the dog is sick or
the vomit of a dog or the feces of a dog
or the blood of a dog or the urine of a
dog. Is it only the saliva?
Right? The answer is all of the dog
has the same ruling
because the saliva of anything
is
usually often more
pure or less
filthy than things the waste,
right? However, why didn't the Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam mention that?
Because he is mentioning things
that people come in contact with,
right? A dog isn't going to come and
urinate on a person's dishes. This is
not common.
When a person sets his dish out and he
goes in his tent and a wild dog comes by
and he starts drinking from his dish. He
shooed the dog away. This is the
instance that the prophet is speaking
about here. Sallallahu alayhi wasallam.
Not very bizarre outlier incidents where
urine and feces and blood and so forth,
these things all have the same ruling.
Right? And this is what we refer to as
qiyas al-awla.
[Arabic recitation]
mentioned today is purifying
the dog's saliva.
So, we know for a fact here that all
animals which are impermissible to eat
are considered to be a type of filth and
especially
a dog because we have a heightened level
of purification process to purify.
Right?
And
there are other animals that fall into
this as well, which we will discuss when
we get to that inshallah ta'ala.
[Arabic recitation]
Got in the doors. Yeah, yeah.